où
n'a pas eu de dépistage c'est juste que
j'ai senti une boucle sur vingt cinq ans
j'ai pris ma douche
tout simplement il ya à partir de là
j'ai vu mon médecin parce que ja et d'en
avant j'avais des kystes donc je pensais
que c'était un simple kyste
[Musique]
c'est un peu le monde qui s'écroule
surtout que à 36 ans on pense pas avoir
un cancer
j'ai tout de suite pensé à mes enfants
c'était très compliqué et puis après on
fait avec puis montez pas quoi
[Musique]
c'était très angoissant c'était surtout
le fait que tous les examens toutes les
consultations tous les traitements se
sont faits et j'étais tout seul ça
n'allait pas attendre parce que j'étais
vraiment déjà un stade un peu limite
donc ça aurait pu être plus compliquée
encore le traitement et j'ai quand même
des enfants qui sont reste jeune et du
coup je voulais voilà donc battre pour
eux pour moi pour ma famille
[Musique]
aujourd'hui je vais bien je suis en
rémission du coup depuis y ait le moins
de mecs
quasiment un an jour pour jour la
découverte
je suis encore en traitement un
traitement c'est l'hormonothérapie
[Musique]
ça encore plus important parce que c'est
vrai que beaucoup d'idées reçues à ce
moment que le cancer du sein en arrive
après 50 ans alors qu'il ya de plus en
plus de cancers du sein qui avant 40 ans
et du coup il faut vraiment penser voilà
se palper à se toucher pas avant
de toucher pendant la douche
regarder si on ne sent pas une boule au
niveau du sens parce que là bas ça peut
vous sauver la vie
[Musique]